get your ancient fertility totems ready
we have the latest episode of american
horror stories and i have to say
this was my favorite one so far in this
video we'll be breaking down episode 5
ball and all the easter eggs and
connections to the greater ahs
universe so make sure your baby isn't
being collected by a demon and hit that
like and subscribe button i come out
with ahs videos every week
episode 5 centers around ahs alum billy
lord's character
liv whitley billy has been a regular in
american horror story first appearing
in season seven's cult and then an aids
apocalypse and
1984. in this episode she and her
husband matt are doing
everything possible to get pregnant
including in vitro fertilization which
is why the beginning of the episode
starts at a fertility clinic but on
their way out a helpful assistant pulls
liv aside and gives her an
ancient fertility totem because you know
that's totally normal
some of you may also have noticed how
she remarks on liv's husband
being hot not the most professional
thing to say if you
want to keep your job but we'll later
find out bernadette the assistant here
is secretly seeing matt
but more on that in a bit the assistant
says that if you place the totem
underneath the bed during intimacy
you'll stand a better chance of getting
pregnant
and at this point liv is willing to try
anything
she puts it under the bed and we see the
edges of the frame
blur which has been a technique used in
previous ahs seasons
to signify magic liv inherited this
giant mansion from her granddad which
becomes a pivotal plot point later on
and as she makes love with her husband
atop the freaky demon totem we fast
forward 16 months to liv and her new
baby boy
aaron the totem has seemingly worked but
liv who wanted nothing more than to have
a child has completely changed
she's irritable and is on the edge of
tossing the baby in a dumpster
such a [ __ ] mistake later liv will
find that that totem is still
under her bed i guess they don't vacuum
under there this time however the totem
has
changed and instead of throwing it out
she places it in a shoebox as you do
liv confides in matt that all she's ever
wanted was a baby but now she feels like
she's a horrible mother
he recommends seeing dr berger who
specializes in hormone and postpartum
disorders
and maybe that's not so bad of an idea
as later that night she believes she
sees a demon
overlooking her kid after a few sessions
with dr berger
liv is feeling pretty good she makes her
husband coffee is excited for his
recurring role on
ncis and things are finally looking up
that is until she finds a new
demon totem this one with wings and
horns in her baby's crib so of course
she instantly blames the maid for
putting it there who upon
seeing the totem does the sign of the
cross and quits
this is also a good time to mention the
production design in the episode which i
absolutely loved although it's sparse
almost the entire episode is decorated
in black and white tones
symbolizing the dichotomy between good
and evil liv thinks she hears noises
coming from the venn so like any good
girl in a horror movie she goes to
investigate finding the entire basement
has been ripped apart
and when she tells this to her husband
he merely dismisses it as the work of
raccoons
liv does some research into this ancient
sumerian fertility totem finding it's
the demon ball
said to be one of the principal kings of
hell she even does some audio work on
the baby monitor recordings increasing
the speed to hear a voice that says
i want him matt concerned for his wife
brings over dr berger who thinks liv
might be overstressed
suffering from sleep deprivation and
pareidolia when the mind starts seeing
patterns and tries to make connections
the i want him audio recording would be
an example of audio paradolia like in
1969 when a detroit dj
started a hoax by claiming that if you
play the beatles song
revolution 9 backwards you can hear the
phrase paul is dead
dr berger prescribes liv some zoloft and
she starts feeling
a bit better enough so to play a game of
ouija with matt's college friends
now one of these friends rory has
actually been in a previous season of
american horror story the actor chad
james buchanan played stu in season 8's
apocalypse
of course things don't go according to
plan when the ouija board spells out the
phrase
he is mine liv lashes out throwing the
board into the fire and she gets in a
huge argument with matt who says he's
had enough of her outbursts
i should also mention i enjoyed ball's
appearance coinciding with storms since
ball
is also known to be the god of storms so
liv goes back to bernadette the
assistant she got that totem from
and wants answers bernadette said she
used to be a drug addict and only
when she turned to paganism was she
healed of her addiction
her parents also dabbled in the sacred
arts and her places furnished in ancient
grimoires and even a monkey paw
bernadette says that liv must conduct a
ritual using a
special consecrated blade in order to
banish the demon from her home and it
just so happens matt is on a night shoot
that evening so she'll have the whole
place to herself for this ritual
liv conducts the ceremony speaking in
latin and cutting her hand to let the
blood flow on the totem when fog starts
to emanate around her it seems like the
ritual is working until she hears her
baby scream
she turns around and accidentally stabs
matt in the chest
we fast forward two weeks where liv has
voluntarily put herself into a mental
asylum she tells matt that she won't
come home until she knows she's safe
it's here we see the big twist of the
episode matt has been seeing bernadette
and this has all been a ploy between him
and his friends to get liv's money
matt says once his lawyers get through
with liv she'll be committed
indefinitely those sounds of the demon
planted speakers
the fog machine set up by matt's friend
and ball himself well that's rory doing
some acting in a demon getup matt even
switched liv's medication with a
psychoactive cocktail and had the baby
monitor
purposely glitch matt is congratulated
with a bj and if you're keeping count
this season that's number four
the gang celebrates their devious plan
knowing that once the situation is all
settled they'll be set for life and matt
plans on shipping his son out to a
boarding school
forever but suddenly a fog creeps in and
demonic noises emanate throughout the
house
which is impossible since they disabled
all the speakers and the fog machine
the real ball demon appears and brutally
massacres all the college friends
except for matt who is taken into police
custody and framed for the murders of
his friends
liv visits matt in jail where we learn
liv tried bernadette's banishing spell
which actually turned out to be a
real summoning spell ball came to life
and viciously murdered matt's friends
while matt was being interrogated for
their murders he told the cops the real
story of wanting liv's money so you can
see liv
isn't too pleased with matt he warns her
not to go back into the house but she
does so anyway
ball is under her control wanting to be
released
and she says she will release him on one
condition she give him
another baby and while this episode does
center around a demon the real demon is
actually that of gaslighting
a husband who makes her wife think she's
gone crazy when it was
all an elaborate ruse it really calls
into question who the real demon was
in this episode if you shout out all the
glaring plot holes like how matt said he
didn't want to get live pregnant but
bernadette gave liv a fertility totem i
think this was the best american horror
stories
episode so far it had twists the pacing
felt better and the overall
tone combined with production design
made this a standout as far as i know
there are only two more episodes left
until ahs double feature comes out which
i hope to cover
every episode of thanks for watching
everyone let me know what you thought of
ball in the comments below and as always
like subscribe and for more bad takes
you can follow me on twitter and
instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much